Let me give you a very quick refresher on encryption. There are two families of
encryption systems. One is the private key cryptosystem. And in the private key
cryptosystem both the sender and the receiver sse symmetric keys for encryption
of the data and decryption of the data. A common private key system that we all
are using probably on an every day basis is passwords. When we log
into either a corporate network or a university network. We use a username
and password and that is using a private key encryption systems. The
idea is simple. The sender takes the data that they want to
send a receiver and encrypts the data using a key and this key
is a private key that is known only
to the sender and the receiver space and nobody
else. So by encrypting the data with this key
they produce what is called a cyphertext and the
cyphertext can go on insecure links. Anybody can see
the bit pattern of the cyphertext, but in order
to make sense out of the cyphertext they have
to decrypt it. And to decrypt it they need
the key and the key is only available between the sender and the receiver. So
this is where Salsa's principle comes into play.
That is, publish the design, but protect the
key. The keys are protected between the sender
and the receiver. You're publishing the method by
which you are transfering information between sender and
receiver. Namely, using a private key encryption system.
But, for any bad guy to access information that is flowing on the
wire they have to have the key in order to make sense out
of the data that is flowing. And you make breaking the key hard
enough, computationally, that the system is secure. Now
one of the problems with the private key system is the fact that the
keys have to be distributed to the
sender and the receiver and key distribution problem
is one of the difficulties with private key
cryptosystems. Especially as the size of the organization
becomes larger and larger. The public key cryptosystem
overcomes this key distribution problem. And in this
case there is a public key which is
published. The name itself suggests the idea behind
the public key cryptosystem. And that is, anyone
can create an encrypted data by taking this public
key, which is available, let's say published in the
Yellow Pages. They can take the public key, take
the data that they want to send and encrypt it, and send it on the wire. But
in order to decrypt the data. The public key
is no good. You need a private key that
is the only way to decrypt this
data. Well, in other words, the mathematical underpinning
of the public key cryptosystem is that there
are asymmetric keys, a pair of keys for
information exchange. In order to encrypt you use
a key that is a public key. Anybody
can have access to that. But in order to decrypt that, you need a private key.
And, conversion of data into a cyphertext using the public key
is a one-way function, which is not reversible. Similarly, converting the
encrypted message into the original data using the private key is another
one-way function. So one-way functions are the mathematical basis for the
public key cryptosystem. So now, the way you would send data, if you're the
sender, take the data, encrypt it using
the public key. You create a cyphertext. Once
you have the cyphertext, you cannot convert it back to the data using the public
key. The only entity that can convert
the cyphertext back to its original data is
the entity that has the private key.
The other part of this asymmetric key infrastructure,
namely, the private key and using the
private key, you can decrypt the cyphertext and
create the original data. So this is the workflow for a sender to encrypt the
data, clear the cypher text, send it
to the receiver, receiver decrypts it using the
private key, and produces the original data.